bag of sugar you can do
it's uh really a fallacy because
sometimes you just need sheer strength
now this is
to me
a technique
for women because if i do this and now
do this
the technique has to rub up
through my breastbone
all right
and that's
you know possibly rude for ladies to do
that so i mean i don't know you know but
so if i do this
i've got a chance now when you drop this
elbow and countering me and
punching me or whatever so it depends
how strong you are
you know so if you do it
yeah so
i'm just saying for women you know if
you take it off your
breast bone
now i should start it i can feel it
getting struck against me so i'm going
to get even stronger
right so so i'm afraid
to me it's not a
woman's technique
because it needs to be there so she
doesn't feel my strength she doesn't
feel my strength she feels it now when i
start returning
see
but here
see i can turn as much light as you can
go yeah oh i'm going to budge in the
face
so
because i'm old i'm not sure about the
gender neutral and all the other
technology words that we have to use now
i'm just saying it's not a great
technique for ladies because you've got
to use strength you know if you're
looking after your own body
you've got things
so this technique has to go
up the breastbone so
so i was reading about oceansian when he
got a 70 there's a lot of techniques he
didn't do
but if we do this one now i can get a
saying here
even that doesn't look like a sankhya
because i've got this arm lock that's it
tap tap tap on that so that's the main
thing
so let's just
and then when it gets about there see
this hand now is coming to me so that
she doesn't get away from me now
this can be done without using strength
and you you find the mechanics
very simple as you'll see we'll find out